foreign
[Music]
ER Jen Wilson and welcome to this foam
independent presents q a for the Netflix
short documentary The Martha Mitchell
effect special thanks to our lead
sponsor hifa and our virtual screenings
partner Vision media and now please
welcome our guests the directors of the
Martha Mitchell effect and alvarage and
co-director Deborah mcclutchey thank you
so much for joining us today
so we have a lot of members of film
independent that are aspiring filmmakers
and so I like to start with chin about
um how each of you started in filmmaking
um let's start with Anne
sure
um
I started
many years ago it feels like now
um I uh I didn't study film as an
undergrad
um but I became more interested in film
after I graduated and started making
super AIDS was traveling and then sort
of found my path into documentary film
editing
um and I went to grad school you know
moved to New York City
um and was a shooter for a while and
then just sort of made my way back to
editing and that's where I've sort of
been ever since for my day job
okay for you Deborah
yeah I studied film in college
um and in the Midwest and so I worked a
little bit with Friends making films
after college
um doing all sorts of things shooting
producing
um smaller independent type stuff uh
moved to San Francisco and started
working in documentary film in San
Francisco and was there for a couple of
years before all my friends left and
moved to New York so I followed them and
came to New York and started out in
documentary television
um doing like associate producing type
things
um and then made my way into
distribution for a long time
and then wanted to make a film so then I
got back into
making films with this one this is our
directorial debut so
so
I personally had never heard of Martha
Mitchell until the the Julia Roberts TV
series that was on gaslit
for for the two of you how
um did you first learn about Martha and
what was it about her that made you want
to make a film about her
do you want to start
I just started either way
let me check
um well we actually learned about Martha
from a podcast
um and we we thought how could whoa wait
who is this person wait this is someone
who was fabulous and hilarious and
somehow seminal in the Watergate scandal
yet we had never neither of us had ever
heard of her uh so we did a little bit
of digging and found some amazing videos
of her
um and thought and there hadn't been a
documentary and
realize also the more that we dug into
the tapes because we started like hey
maybe this is a possibility we realized
that
um that she was actually she wasn't
actually more of an instrumental
character in in the Scandal and that she
had been lost to history as a result of
speaking to power you know she was
essentially discredited by the Nixon
Administration you know who leveraged
perceived mental illness and addiction
against her and hence she was silenced
and sort of became a hidden figure in
history and we thought wow this is like
a perfect time to sort of like exhume
her story and then also kind of give
return her agency to her you know sort
of like try to keep the film as much in
her voice as possible
uh to tell to retell her story for
today's audience
yeah I would just add to that also it's
a story that's always told through All
the President's Men that's what everyone
always thinks about when it comes to
Watergate and to have this really
vibrant character female character who
was someone who was sort of instrumental
and did play a role at that time be lost
to history
um felt really unfair in a lot of ways
um and it was a story as Anne said you
know she was speaking truth to power and
um not many Republicans were doing that
in our current political era at the
moment and so she was a really
intriguing figure in that sense too
because it kind of
um it uh it resonated for today's
political times as well
so the the archival footage that you use
in the film which is terrific and gives
us such a great picture of Who Martha
was in public
um was it a very did you have a very
difficult time finding archival for her
or were was there a lot in existence
that was easily
searchable
um there was yeah we found a lot through
the Nixon Library all the Super 8 teams
ironically
yeah
um all the Super 8 tapes that illustrate
um you know the administration we found
at the Nixon library and those are
really wonderful to have and
um really accessible they had some
interviews with Martha as well that we
were able to uncover in their collection
um which is where we really saw how
charismatic she was intelligenic and
just like a fun character to watch but
we also found materials in you know like
a Northeast film archive that hadn't
been uncovered since they had first been
seen back in the 70s there was a
university in Arkansas where I uncovered
some material from her
um and later on in the process there was
an interview with her from 7b4 I believe
it was that was sitting in a news
journalist attic
um and we somehow Came Upon him which
I'm totally forgetting exactly how we
did but he had this in his attic and he
made it available to us to use as well
so it was really a you know a deep
digging process in a variety of
different archives not just the Nixon
Library
what so what it was it do you think that
started prompting Martha to just start
speaking her mind to the Press because
for a while she was sort of you know
playing the game and sort of Towing the
party line I mean I feel like she was
always really outspoken probably more
outspoken than they really wanted her to
be but for a while she was saying all
the right things
what was it do you think that prompted
her to say to something like the Vietnam
War
stinks out loud to someone like Helen
Thomas
well in that particular instance she
actually had a son from a previous
marriage who was fighting in Vietnam at
that time so I think I think it was
personal for her and that's that's I
think why she started to speak out and
you know I think maybe she was also
testing the waters a little bit you know
I mean yes you're absolutely correct she
had been Towing the party line they had
they loved that that she would um draw
attention from the Press since Nixon's
Administration was very buttoned up they
never really talked to them so so they
appreciated that but then that
particular incident was when she really
crossed the line and
um yeah I think she just continued to I
think she liked the attention I think
she you know I think to maybe anticipate
what your your next question is I think
you know eventually she she spoke out
during the actual Watergate break-in
because she she knew something was up
and I think you know her she really
wanted to
to speak truth to power but I also think
that there was a selfish side that she
was trying to protect her husband from
um you know being basically thrown to
the bus and being involved in the
Scandal
uh the movie starts with the a rather
stunning quote from Nixon saying I'm
convinced that if there had been no
Martha there would have been no
watergates and then later is a quote
from Martha saying Richard Nixon
destroyed my marriage so obviously no
love lost between these two
um
uh a do you think do you think that's
true there wouldn't have been a
Watergate without
uh Martha and two what what
was it do you think that Nixon thought
Martha's contribution to the Scandal was
sure I think
I think Nixon was really skateboarding
in that quote
he you know they had characterized her
as with you know this perceived mental
illness and that she drank too much and
that she was basically a crazy lady
um and she you know all these aunts of
hers sort of distracted her husband John
Mitchell and therefore he wasn't up to
the task of his job because he had this
wife that he always had to pay attention
to and take care of and so that was part
of that quote of what Nixon was saying
um and there was a sort of Love Triangle
going on between the three of them and
Martha was quite jealous that her
husband's attention was always elsewhere
oftentimes with Nixon
um so that played into part of the whole
um yeah the love triangle that happened
with them and sort of the whole like
drama that ensued
so Martha says the turning point for her
was California
um
and do you want to talk about what the
incident was in California that changed
everything for Martha
sure
um
so
Prime of the Watergate break in June 17
1972.
um
Martha was in California she was in
Southern California at a resort hotel
she was there with a Nixon delegation
who were essentially fundraising with
the committee to re-elect the president
and as soon as her husband heard about
the break-in he was called back to
Washington and he told Martha oh you
just stay here and relax you sit by the
pool you you know you've had a hectic
time
but that was obviously a red flag for
her she knew something was up and
essentially The Bodyguard kept and the
other people kept the Press from Martha
because they didn't want her to get
upset or they didn't want her to you
know possibly speak out so of course
what she did see the newspapers when she
did get wind of what was going on she
asked a lot of questions called her
husband everyone tried to pacify her and
then eventually she got in touch with
Helen Thomas and Helen Thomas started
asking her about the Watergate break-in
and she started speaking out and at that
point The Bodyguard
uh theoretically this is what we we have
been our research has shown
um it has been proven that uh The
Bodyguard essentially pulled the
telephone card sorry sorry
let me start over
the secret the security guard pulled the
telephone cord out of the wall and
um and contained Martha
and eventually called a doctor who
tranquilized her against her will
to keep quiet
yeah
sorry go ahead I was just gonna say I
think that was a really pivotal moment
for Martha where she realized that she
actually could be in danger you know
that she that they would be willing to
go to those Great Lengths to silence her
and I think that really terrified her
and affected her for the rest of her
life where she became very paranoid and
scared and uh rightly so
yeah I mean that you know there's a
quote of hers in the in the film where
she says you know they're trying to kill
me and she she said that multiple times
kind of throughout her life post water
day break in
she said also a few times
that they tried to have her committed do
you think that was true as well
you know it it's unclear it doesn't it
wouldn't surprise me I mean she
certainly spent some time at this
um
what I would consider more of a dry out
facility in um called the Craig's house
and it's unclear if her husband made her
go or if she went voluntarily but I
think that because she had spent time
there or she had been sent there in the
past you know at least once in the past
that there that there was always that
looming threat like these men are gonna
commit me and they're and they're doing
that not to help me but to silence me
so this is sort of a conspiracy theory
question
um
uh people love to have you know these
stories about Watergate break-in
um
the
the break-in seems particularly badly
planned
um
particularly the fact that you know it
was in John Mitchell's own apartment
building and involved one of his main
security guards uh James McCord
did you ever think that that was by
Design
or that was just
and it's so much of people who just had
no idea what they were doing and did a
completely bungled
job
it was a bungled burglary I mean that's
essentially what John Dean has has
expressed to us like he said in the film
yeah I mean they had no idea in fact
John Dean says you know he's he's
skeptical of how much Martha knew
because he says no one knew anything
like no one knew what was going on so so
yeah I think it was um I think there
were some nefarious activities going on
behind
uh you know without necessarily Nixon's
overt approval and then there were lots
of of crazy ideas floated by G Gordon
Liddy that were you know theoretically
approved or not approved and I think
that's that's sort of
you know there were uh yeah
that's essentially what happened
um so do you think that if Martha had
known that sooner that her own husband
was involved in it as deeply as he was
that she would have gagged herself over
it or you know muffled herself from
speaking to the Press over it or no
great question I I actually think she
had an idea that he was behind it and
that's perhaps why she was speaking out
so much to protect him and sort of point
the finger at Nixon so it wasn't so her
husband wouldn't be completely the Fall
Guy or the Fall Guy
um
but yeah I'm not I'm not sure it's
unclear how much she knew about her
husband's culpability or not
um
close to the or in the in the middle of
the film there's a quote from from Bob
Bob Woodward I think saying
Watergate was much more than a break-in
it was on and I'm uh not using the
direct quote here but it was a
conspiracy to steal an election and it
worked
do you believe that
um
Nixon's re-election was stolen a stolen
election
I think Bob Woodward was right in his
quote yeah and I think
um you know Watergate was such a huge
scandal
and they had actually tried to break
into the Watergate before the actual
break-in in June 17th so it was a series
of scandalous events that had happened
and you know dirty tricks that they
wanted to do to try and undermine the
other candidates
um and a lot of it did work
um you know Ed musky
um was totally discredited and he was
the front runner for the Democrats at
the time an a strong candidate
um
so yeah it was a threat to democracy in
a way that was very serious that seems
quaint to us now in terms of the threats
that we've been seeing for the past
several years
um but it was absolutely a compromised
election
yeah I would agree with that I would
just add that John Dean told us this
funny story of how
they they uh men who were you know on
the campaign tour would put their shoes
outside of their doors to get them
polished and so they so somebody from
the committee
um stole muskies shoes and all of his
you know Compadres and so then they
didn't have shoes they couldn't go to
the next stop because they only traveled
with one pair of shoes so that was the
kind of you know nefarious kind of kooky
stuff that they would do that's amazing
that's a really amazing story
um
so uh you know this this film The Story
of Martha
I think really illustrates uh
in such a great way but also in such a
sad way uh about women's position in
society at at this time period was that
part of what attracted you to do the
project
yeah definitely I mean Ann and I had
thought about like do we know any
cabinet members wife's name today
um you know it's really women really did
take a back seat then
um but they still kind of take it back
yeah
um so yeah absolutely the fact that she
was so popular actually you know she
became a celebrity they say it in in the
tapes you know Nixon and Mitchell both
acknowledge that because she became a
celebrity
um
but she didn't
yeah she
sorry I lost my train of thought that's
okay
um yeah but that's yeah and go ahead
yeah I mean I would just say the
parallels
um you know are are sort of uncanny to
today right I mean like from Hillary
Clinton all the way to like Christine
blasey Ford
um I mean to now during January 6
Cassidy Hutchinson so you know people
these women women who are speaking out
are constantly gas gas lit right so so
that was very much in our mind when we
were starting the film we saw what was
happening we saw what happened with
Trump vis-a-vis Hillary Clinton and
you know it was around me too when we
started this so we knew it was kind of a
perfect storm of
uncannyness and kind of uncanny valley
in terms of what was happening today
um so do you want to talk about what
happened to to Martha at the end it's
interesting there was an interview in
there
where she said something that indicated
to me that she really did have pretty
bad PTSD from being attacked by those
guards
um but can can you just talk about what
uh Martha's ending was like because she
actually passed away before some of
these guys went to jail for Watergate
right
they they uh so so many of them had been
indicted by
but while she was still alive so she
actually did have some Vindication at
the end of her life
um you know she was alive when Nixon
resigned and so she sort of went on a
little bit of a press tour
um to kind of uh speak her mind again
have people listen to her story and she
was very popular because I think the
Press sort of realized that she was
right that she she was the first one to
point the finger at Nixon and they
should have listened to her so she did
have a slight Vindication but then
subsequently after that she came down
with
um uh you know a very serious illness
and died very prematurely in her mid-50s
so yes in some ways she didn't get the
full Vindication she deserved and then
it was lost to history so yes
uh so the in the end
um you know we have the footage from her
funeral that's uh with that flower
arrangement that says Martha was right
which is the best thing one of the best
things I've ever seen in life
um do you have any theories about who
sent that do you think it was Helen
Thomas or or somebody like Helen Thomas
no I don't no I don't think it was Helen
Thomas I'd be very successful Allentown
is
um I don't know it was an admirer it was
someone who really you know saw that she
was speaking the truth and
yeah in terms of her story when we
learned that that this flower
arrangement turned up at her funeral
that was just like another piece of the
story where it was just like oh my gosh
I can't believe that we had never heard
this before
um such a dramatic ending um and so
poignant you know because she did have a
lot of popular support in America
um and a lot of people did feel like she
was telling the truth and didn't get her
due
um so yeah I I don't know who sent that
and I don't know if anyone will ever be
able to find out who said that but I
would be very curious to know
I noticed that a lot of clips of like
major news outlets covering her and the
things that she said
seem to be making fun of her
did you find a lot of that or was there
anybody who sort of took took what she
said actually seriously
yeah I mean that was
um that was another Revelation and
watching the archival was how much these
you know you know 100 male
um talking head broadcasters would sort
of tow the party line of Nixon and and
look at her in a very skeptical way and
so they you know we sort of use them as
proxy for the sort of the mainstream
narration and how they they colluded in
a way into the gaslighting um but the
there were there were other broadcasters
who who didn't
um didn't necessarily support that I
mean Maury Povich didn't support that he
had he had a um kind of a seminal
political show that was local to DC
called Panorama
um that you see at the end of the film
and he supported her um and then in then
mostly female journalists
um also came together and supported her
it wasn't just um Helen Thomas it was
um uh you know
um sorry uh it wasn't just Helen Thomas
it was when Zola McClendon and others
so um the the interview that you have at
the end with with Helen was a great uh
cap to this where she's you know being
asked if she thought that Marx was
really crazy and
and and Helen was like no I don't think
so at all and I actually think that she
was visionary
and
um
do you think that that Helen
Helen Thomas put herself at risk
uh defending Martha and do you think
that
that Helen put herself in her
credibility at risk to defend Martha
do you want to take that I think so yeah
that that interview bite is so
interesting to me because she kind of
hesitates a little bit when she answers
the question
um because Martha was a kooky character
you know she was her personality was
quite fun and playful and not serious
all the time
um but to call her a quit to even be
asked that question was she a crazy lady
it's kind of ridiculous one thing for a
journalist to do
um so her hesitation is always very
interesting to me in in that interview
and I think she did put her herself on
the line to defend Martha
um it obviously probably wasn't very
popular thing to do so she did put her
credibility on the line but she really
did believe her and she didn't really
think that she was Visionary and
prophetic as she had said in that
interview so
I mean I think I think Helen Thomas was
smart enough to to realize that yeah
maybe there was some risk in supporting
Martha Mitchell but she had this amazing
sword source of Martha Mitchell she was
the only one who would speak from the
Nixa Administration so she would take
her 2 A.M or 3 A.M calls because she
knew she would get dirt and so it was a
very transactional relationship I mean
Martha relied upon her and other female
journalists to you know for friendship
and support but to get the word out and
you know Helen Thomas relied on her as
this great source I mean even Bob
Woodward acknowledged us he was like I
was I'm still jealous of Helen Thomas
that she scooped me from speaking to
Martha Mitchell right after the break-in
like he was still talking about it to
this day
um so I'm wondering just to to close out
what for each of you what do you hope
that the takeaway from this short is
when people watch it
um
um yeah I mean I can start
um you know I think listen I I hope that
people are entertained that they learn
about this hidden figure
um of you know this big political
Scandal of the last century
um I also feel like her story you know
is a reminder
um that there are personal costs to
speaking truth to power
um but also that that soft power is
vital that it's really important and can
be very impactful that we you know we
need to listen to these overlooked
voices or people we might at first deem
inconsequential
um you know what might have happened had
people listened to her Clarion call
earlier like what what you know what um
what would we have salvaged you know
about our democracy I'm not sure if
that's anything but I I do think it's
important to to sort of question all
that
yeah I agree with all of that also that
there are hidden histories
um there are many layers to some of
these stories and you can't just believe
the the common narrative that's always
told necessarily
um like I said earlier this has always
been all the president's men's story and
he's this amazing woman
um who had a really important story
um that hopefully you know people are
learning through our film
um so definitely that's a huge takeaway
and also that you know speaking truth to
power is so incredibly important and to
do it
within the group that originally like
accepted you and you belong to and
speaking truth to power to them is a
very courageous and brave thing to do
and it's the right thing to do and
Martha knew that and she took the risk
to do the right thing and hopefully our
film would Inspire some people to do the
right thing
all right well thank you so much to the
two of you for coming to talk about your
film uh I enjoyed it so so much and
um good luck to you thank you so much
Jen
foreign
[Music]